perfectly.
>> We're still trying to figure
out what some of these things
were, and they were not in the
category of the balloon.
>> Let's bring in Gordon Chang,
an analyst on China and north
Korea.
Good to see you.
You said you think Russia could
possibly also be involved with
these objects.
You tweeted last night, "We will
be in the fight soon.
China and Russia are making sure
that we're at the end of decades
of general peace."
That's a terrifying proposition.
We still don't know what those
other three objects were, and
there's a chance we might never
know.
Do you really think that this
could kick off nonstop conflict
if not World War III?
>> That's a possibility, Jake.
Remember, the objects that were
shot down on Friday and Saturday
entered North American air space
from the north.
And that means that they
probably passed over Russia.
That means perhaps Russia --
these are Russian objects, maybe
China launched them from Russia,
or maybe China launched them
from China, but they floated
over Russia, which means that
Russia presumably gave approval
to them.
We know that China's top
diplomat is going to be in
Moscow in a couple days.
That follows by a couple weeks
the vice foreign minister going
to Moscow.
XI jinping, the Chinese ruler,
is supposed to go to the Moscow
this year, and we've seen China
be all in on the Russian war
effort in Ukraine.
So, the conclusion is that China
and Russia are forming a durable
partnership.
>> And what are these objects,
do you think?
Do you think they're just
provocative, they're trying to
needle us, surveillance,
potentially weapons?
>> We don't know.
Apparently they were smaller so
they might be less dangerous
than the balloon that entered
into the usair space on January
28th from the south, which was
Chinese.
We don't know.
And as you heard from those
senators who attended a
briefing, I don't think the
administration knows either.
But one thing, I think president
Biden needs to address the
American public.
Even if we don't know.
And the American people need to
hear it from our leader.
You know, Canada's Justin
Trudeau spoke to Canada about
the object that was over their
country.
President Biden needs to do the
same thing.
>> I want to get your take on
how the U.S. Is handling this in
terms of communication with the
Chinese leaders.
Obviously, secretary of state
Antony blinken canceled his trip
to China after that first
Chinese spy balloon.
We're told that the ministry of
defense in China has not taken
calls from secretary of defense
Austin or other attempts at
outreach, and the state
department spokesman Ned price
said yesterday the U.S. Believes
in keeping lines of
communication open with China.
How should the Biden
administration be addressing
this when it comes to
communication with China?
>> I don't think we should be
talking to China.
China right now is not in a
position to deal with the united
States in good faith, and so I
don't see why we should be
communicating with them.
You know, it's an article of
faith among Americans that you
talk to an adversary, talk to an
enemy.
But by doing that, we've
emboldened the worst elements in
Chinese political system by
showing that bridge rant acts
are able to get the united
States to a position where we
look like we're desperately
trying to pursue China.
We heard president Biden in that
conversation with pbs say, well,
this incident, this spy balloon
incident, is not going to change
u.s./china relations.
Essentially, that was telling
China there's going to be no
cost for what was obviously a
very dangerous act.
So we need to have a new way of